hey everybody what's going on just left
the pool had a great swim it's a
beautiful day here in Malibu Canyon and
we are going to go drop in on my buddy
Greg
he's an architect friend of mine our
kids are friends and stuff like that and
he has decided to give the whole plant
power thing a world which I'm very
excited about he's been at it for a
couple of weeks now and I thought we
would drop in on him go over to his
house talk to him about how he's done it
how he's feeling and
maybe pick up a few tips you know so
what do you think let's check him out
hey buddy hey how you doing yeah what's
going on tell me a little bit about what
you what you were what you were doing
before like in terms of like diet and
exercise is probably a period at least
10 years where I just did not exercise I
just literally so came to like working a
day job having to get up at 7 o'clock
and got into this routine that was just
so regimented that I was always
justifying to myself why I couldn't work
out right he's a reason and then
probably about three years ago I had a
moment where kind of a dead wracking
moment were to play basketball some
friends
nice to do hygienic in college I would
to dump the ball and I just couldn't
even barely touch the net
what do you used to how tall are you 63
right so you were used to being able to
dunk and stuff like that right yeah
so that was kind of a moment where it
was dawning on me that I was going
downhill and it just didn't seem right
going up in our generation of our
parents generation there was this
thought that you got to a certain age
and you know gravity just took over and
you just didn't do certain things you
didn't you didn't do a flight except a
certain age that was nonsense but seeing
other people like you that were out
there doing it and not just staying in
shape but actually competing bananas
dates ice that's it nothing else no
where's the kale man I'll put some kale
there look up so the garden magnets are
over
it's your drink you got kale in the
garden no way man this is all inspired
by the movement and just so everyone
knows like it's not that much land you
just got a little side plot here and you
just decided what it looks like some
beets they're different beats those are
probably ready to go any time artichoke
kale I've got like three different
varieties of kale broccoli wow that's
pretty cool it parsley at which time a
juice man like tending to all this this
tour literally it took like four or five
hours but I promise you if you do this
the energy you get back for just
nurturing the plants it'll give it back
to you I'm great for the kids to see
these plants grow and water I'll be
today I think I think that they just
give it's almost like having another pet
my house these plants you just they
become a part of your life there's
something really nice about eating the
food at Brown and so yeah no doubt it is
a little bit of non sweetened coconut
mal can have but we're gonna try before
you put any water in there no no water
that's always a thing all right
it's great that it's like a banana
milkshake you know I'd say that the Nana
base drinks are really good for
budget-conscious people and kids love
the two oh yeah you know because it
gives it that dairy kind of feel to it
you know and they have like this
richness to them that actually satiates
you up here if you get hungry tonight
I'd strongly recommend getting something
like this popsicle maker yeah this is a
little runny like fifty dollars but you
can have absolute control over the
popsicles we just you can actually blend
them up puree anything and within about
eight ten minutes it makes a popsicle so
the kids have fun doing it they actually
take part in the process they pick the
fruit vegetables we mix them up we pour
them in there and literally ten minutes
later that's cool so what is that like
mango popsicle only mango of just puree
games really don't know anything they're
open to the idea in fact they they just
they love eating fruit and vegetables
and with the garden they got and picked
their fruit or vegetables well yeah the
key is involving them a minute you know
and I mean and they develop in it but an
emotional attachment to whether it's
growing the food or preparing the meals
or making the popsicles or whatever
they're doing it and they're
participating in it then there's a
there's a connection there yeah the
wrong was questioned once but I think he
was a vegetarian or vegan but he was
kind of making the claim that you didn't
have to have me to eat this farmer was
out plowing his fields with this massive
kind of oxen pulling pulling him behind
and he said well you have to have your
meat and throw said well what is that
oxen he is pulling you and he's like
grass the energy level that you get from
doing this will actually
make you more fit and feel more in shape
and ultimately now we have two daughters
I just want to be there for them I want
to be able to play with them and be
energetic and that's kind of what
started this whole thing was just
wanting to experience life with my
children at their energy level just
really confident
alright so when's your ultra Saturday
100 or 50 well I signed up for the
hundred two months of training first let
me do yours plant power
Cheers I'm a believer
you